ja meine damen und herren liebe
parteifreunde als wir uns kürzlich im
bundesvorstand gemeinsam darauf
verständigten die vertragsdauer für alle
redner auf dem parteitag recht eng zu
begrenzen weil ich damit sehr
einverstanden wenn es gilt die knappe
zeit eines parteitages so effizient wie
möglich zu nutzen
erst recht wenn er mit soviel
verspätungen unter so abenteuerlichen
bedingungen zustande kommt wie unser
heutiger sozial parteitag meine
ursprüngliche absicht war dann die die
rede dauer jedenfalls schwerpunktmäßig
für eine inhaltliche hinführung zu einer
befassung mit unserem schwerpunkt thema
dieses parteitages zu nutzen und vor
allem zu unseren ansätzen zu einer
modernisierten und zukunftsängsten
alternativen sozialpolitik zu sprechen
das werde ich nun heute aber anders
halten weil dieses thema zwar in der tat
höchst wichtig ist und ich mich auch in
der tat sehr freue dass wir in diesen
tagen
diese noch offene stelle unseres
parteiprogramms endlich werden schließen
können aber es gibt und ich muss sagen
leider noch wichtigeres also ich meine
zu ihnen sprechen zu müssen
darum hier jetzt nur einführend ganz
kurze anmerkungen zur leitantrag und
ergänzenden anträgen der hier im
nachfolgenden tagesordnungspunkt
eingebrachte leitantrag zur
sozialpolitik ist das ergebnis uns sehr
viel vorarbeit in den landes und bundes
fachausschüssen und in der bundes
programmkommission wer dabei war weiß
dass das vorliegende papier
das ergebnis eines langen ringens um die
richtige positionierung ist
alle beteiligten mussten hier über ihren
schatten springen und die zustimmung zum
finalen entwurf hat mancher nur mit der
einen oder vielleicht mit zwei fäusten
in der tasche machen können aber
so ist das wesen der politik in einer
demokratie
sie setzt sich die position des einen
voll durch das gibt es nur in diktaturen
es ist immer auch kompromiss und wer
dazu nicht fähig ist der sollte es
gleich lassen
ich würde es kurz machen als wir uns in
der bundesprogramm kommission im februar
final aber doch mit überwältigender
mehrheit der einigten mag vielleicht
mancher wunsch offen geblieben
aber wir konnten einander die hände
schütteln und sagen diesem leitantrag
können wir so den bundesparteitag als
arbeitsergebnis doch gemeinsam
vorschlagen
und das geschieht nun heute mit mehrheit
einem halben jahr kohona bedingte
verzögerung details zum leitantrag wird
ihnen albrecht glaser vorstellen von
meiner seite möchte ich ihnen sagen dass
sich selbst diesen antrag mittrage und
ihnen zur heutigen annahme empfehle
vielleicht noch ergänzt oder verändert
um den einen oder anderen antrag das
wird die weitere diskussion dieses
parteitages zeigen
ich freue mich auch dies sicherlich
lebhafte diskussion auch mancher weitere
anträge
das ist die wertvolle inhaltliche arbeit
die uns weiterbringt was geschieht denn
hier vorne jetzt gerade nun einen antrag
möchte ich mir erlauben ihrer
geschätzten aufmerksamkeit ganz
besonders zu empfehlen ist wach antrag
ns 1 eingebracht von einer ganzen reihe
von delegierten
so auch von mir selbst entwickelt von
rené springer das eher vorstellen wird
mit dem ich zu diesem thema schon
etliche sehr fruchtbarer fachliche
gespräche geführt habe
hier geht es um die schaffung der
möglichkeit einer wohlgemerkt erprobung
eines neuen sozialpolitisches instrument
auf der basis eines bedingten nicht etwa
bedingungslosen grundeinkommens mit dem
zugleich eine lange liste bisheriger
sozialpolitischer und höchst
bürokratische instrumente der
bestehenden sozialgesetzbücher
komplett ersetzt werden könnte ich bin
mir sicher wir werden auch dazu eine
sehr interessante und lebhafte
diskussion führten nun zu dem
[Applaus]
nun zu dem was ich für unsere partei in
ihrer derzeitigen phase als sogar noch
gravierender erachte hat sie sozial
politisch von der form überlegungen
liebe freunde seien wir bitte ehrlich
miteinander und legen wir auch darin den
mut zur wahrheit an den tag den wir uns
doch aus gutem grund auf die fahnen
geschrieben haben
wenn wir das tun und einmal einen blick
von außen auf unsere partei werfen
dann sind hier nach inzwischen sieben
jahren einer in der geschichte der
bundesrepublik deutschland einmaligen
erfolgsgeschichte nun an einem punkt
angelangt an dem es nicht mehr
automatisch immer weiter nach oben geht
und sich wahlerfolg an war erfolgreich
erstmals müssen wir sogar breitere front
gewahr werden dass alle unsere
bisherigen erfolge mit denen wir die
altparteien aufgemischt haben wie es
niemandem vor uns gelungen ist nun
gefährdet sind wie noch nie ein punkt an
dem wir wenn wir es falsch angehen alle
unsere erfolge virtuell nicht nur nicht
ausbauen oder wenigstens bewahren können
sondern an dem auch noch alles kaputt
gehen kann
und das liegt nun wahrlich nicht an
unseren politischen gegnern
die sind von der merkel union über fdp
und spd bis zu den sogenannten grünen
mindestens so schwach und vor den
problemen unserer zeit erkennbar
versagen wie eh und je im grunde
genommen sogar mehr denn je
in einer solchen phase müssten wir
eigentlich punkten unter zugewinn an
politischem einfluss
stattdessen droht aktuell seien wir
ehrlich eher das gegenteil
wollen wir das abstellen und ändern
wollen wir also zurück auf die
erfolgsspur müssen wir uns die frage
nach den gründen dafür warum es nicht
weiter aufwärtsgeht ehrlich beantworten
tun mir dass liebe freunde
und da sage ich es machen sich einige
vom einfachen mitglied bis in die
führungsriege der zeit leider etwas zu
einfach
die fehlende einheit und geschlossenheit
sei schuld die fehle und deshalb müssten
wir nur alle zusammenstehen und dann
wäre schwupps das problem gelöst
klingt plausibel ist aber ich sagen dass
cloud deutlich so einfach einheit in was
denn eine echte nicht nur gespielte
einheit besteht immer in einer
hinlänglichen summe an inhaltlichen
gemeinsamkeiten als elementare
grundvoraussetzung
erstens also
[Applaus]
erstens also gemeinsamkeiten den
inhaltlichen positionen die bestehe
nicht nur darin die inhaltlichen
positionen der politischen gegner aus
vielerlei sehr guten gründen für
grundfalsch zu halten sondern eben auch
darin was man dem entgegensetzen will
als echte alternative
und da reicht es nicht sich
wechselseitig zu versichern
man sei konservativ da liege doch
bereits die gemeinsamkeit das ist so
einfach denn das kann im begriffs
verständnis vieles heißen einige in
unseren reihen scheinen darunter ein
zurück ins gestern zu verstehen fühlen
sich bei bismarck zu hause und waren
geradezu schwärmerisch diese historische
figur wie propagieren dann
sozialpolitisch so eine art bismarck 21
als lösung der heutigen wirtschafts und
sozialpolitischen probleme des landes
das mag romantisch sein
und es gibt sicher allerlei gründe sich
diese oder jene gute zeit unserer
nationalen vergangenheit zurück zu
wünschen
andere ganz und gar nicht das wissen
gerade wir deutschen
aber es ist vor allem etwas zukunfts
blind mit den rezepten von vorgestern
sind die politischen lösungen von morgen
nämlich nicht zu gestalten
schon gar nicht schon gar nicht
angesichts einer ungeheuren dynamik
einer sich in atemberaubender
geschwindigkeit digitalisieren lebens
und arbeitswelt die af.de liebe freunde
ist keine rückwärtsgewandte partei
sie darf auch keine solche sein will wie
eine erfolgreiche politische zukunft
haben das gestern ist vergangen und wird
nicht wiederkommen
es geht in der politik allein um die
gestaltung der rahmenbedingungen eines
guten morgen für unsere kinder und enkel
der moderne konservative ist deswegen
niemals reaktionär
er versucht vor allem eines gut und
richtig erkannt das wertesystem wichtige
und elementare gesellschaftliche
tugenden wie fleiß eigenverantwortung
ehrlichkeit anstand respekt und auch
demut auf das um vermeintlich neue zu
übertragen
[Applaus]
damit seien sie versichert haben wir
mehr als genug zu tun denn all diese
tugenden drohen in dem von mir schon in
stuttgart 2016 als links rot-grün
versifften 68er geprägten zeitgeist
unwiederbringlich verloren zu gehen
übrigens auch wie sollte es anders sein
in den eigenen reihen
denn letztlich sind auch wenn wir
ehrlich sind auch wir ein spiegelbild
einer sich wandelnden gesellschaft und
dann beginnt es nun schmerzhaft zu
werden und ich wünschte ich müsste
einige der nachfolgenden dinge lieber
nicht ansprechen aber es erscheint mir
zwingend ich halte das für notwendig
gelebte einheit
je mehr freunde verlangt zweitens eben
nicht nur eine hinreichend hohe
gemeinsamkeit dann inhaltlichen
positionen sondern auch an sozialen
verhaltensweisen und gemeinsame oder
jedenfalls kompatiblem sprachgebrauch
und ist das nicht vorhanden dann wird
die forderung nach einheit und
zusammenhalt zur leeren worthülse oder
schlimmer noch geradezu zu einer pseudo
moralischen erpressung
wissen sie wer sich erst in wort oder
handeln tisch sich daneben benimmt um
dann aber sogleich die solidarität der
ganzen partei mit diesem verhalten
einzufordern versucht parteimitglieder
in eine kollektivhaftung für das eigene
fehlverhalten zu nehmen
fand ich hatte
ich halte es für indiskutabel dass dann
als ein verlangen nach vermeintlich
unabdingbare einheit zu bezeichnen nein
liebe freunde ich will ja ganz deutlich
sein lassen wir ruhig die im regen
stehen die zu die nur allzu gerne rum
krakeelen und rump rollen oder auch
andere dazu einladen wie wir das
vergangene woche leider im bundestag
erleben mussten weil sie sich in der
rolle des provokateurs gefallen wie
pubertierende schuljungen und vor allem
der eigenen überschaubar an blase zeigen
zu wollen was für tolle kerle sie doch
sind verweigern wir diesen leuten die
den geschlossen
machen wir uns bitte gemeinsam bewusst
wegen solcher vorkommnisse wählen uns
scharen von menschen dann nicht mehr die
uns bislang gewählt haben und das sind
menschen die fast schon verzweifelt nach
einer guten alternative zu den
altparteien suchen die sie nur zu gerne
in uns sehen möchten aber wegen der
einen oder anderen entgleisungen dann
eben nicht mehr können wir werden nicht
mehr erfolg erzielen nehmen wir immer
aggressiver immer der aber immer
enthemmter auftreten so geht das nicht
im gegenteil liebe freunde so verlieren
wir die vielen menschen die uns auf der
suche nach einer vernünftigen
alternativen zum ganzen politischen
irrsinn der merkelschen politik zu gerne
ihr vertrauen schenken würden das genau
deswegen dann aber nicht mehr können was
wir mehr als alles andere brauchen ist
innerparteilich disziplin
[Applaus]
dazu gehört und adeliges verhalten aller
funktionäre und auch einfache mitglieder
vom parlament bis zum straßenstand dazu
gehört auch eine die probleme glasklaren
ende aber zugleich nicht überzeichnete
der sache gerecht werdende bord war
nehmen wir exemplarisch die kogit 19
krise und unseren umgang damit
es ist gut richtig und absolut zwingend
notwendig dass wir der gesamten
regierung ihren zu teilen geradezu
unglaublich dilettantischen umgang mit
der krise zum vorwurf machen dass wir
aufzeigen dass merkels söders und
sparpolitik in vielen eben gerade nicht
wie behauptet angemessenen und zum gar
nicht verhältnismäßig ist und ist es
richtig wenn wir sagen dass die
partielle außerkraftsetzung von
grundrechten nicht hinnehmbar ist wenn
sie eben nicht zwingend ist
dazu darf man auch kräftige worte der
kritik verwenden verbunden vor allem
auch mit dem konkreten aufzeigen der
fehler und mit eigenen vorschlägen
jemandes stattdessen besser machen
sollte aber ich frage mich ist es
wirklich klug von einer corona diktatur
zu sprechen
wir leben in keiner diktatur sonst
könnten wir diesen parteitag heute wohl
auch kaum so abhalten und die behauptung
dass ich anders stellt im grunde die
systemfrage und bringt uns ohne jede not
in ein fahrwasser
das ist massiv existenziell gefährdet
und die durch den dadurch die darin
liegende maßlosigkeit bei vielen
menschen kopfschütteln auslöst
[Applaus]
und ist es klo geht weiß dass ich damit
dass ich damit auch wie das fernseh ist
es denn klug wenn sich alle funktionäre
ohne jede kritische distanz mit der
sogenannten querdenker bewegung
kritiklos gemein machen
daher engagieren sich bekanntermaßen und
ich will dass konzedieren neben ganz
normalen besorgten und ihrer besorgnis
ausdruck verleihen wollen den bürgern ja
die sind da aber da engagieren sich auch
nicht ganz wenige zeitgenossen deren
skurrile zum teil auch offenen system
feindliche positionen und an sich den
verdacht nahelegen dass bei ihnen
tragischerweise noch nicht mal das
gerade ausdenken richtig funktioniert
geschweige denn echtes querdenken
was das heißt er denn das für ein bild
von unserer partei wenn einige von uns
da jede distanz vermissen lassen und die
üblichen medien sich begierig in ihrer
einseitigen berichterstattung darauf
stürzen und ist es klug mit der ganz
gezielten verwendung des begriffes
ermächtigungsgesetz inferno meter
natürlich hart zu kritisierenden
veränderungen des
infektionsschutzgesetzes zu hantieren
und damit auch ganz bewusst
assoziationen an die ns-zeit und hitlers
machtergreifung 33 zu wecken sollten
sich sollten sich solche vergleiche
angesichts der allgemein bekannten
monstrosität und in dieser dimension
auch singularität der nazibarbarei nicht
eigentlich von selbst verbieten weil
darin nämlich eine implizite
verharmlosung der grauenhaften und taten
je nach finsteren zeit liegt
liebe freunde ich sag das hier und heute
laut klar und deutlich und nehme auch
widerspruch dagegen zur kenntnis ich
sage das kann und darf so keinesfalls
weiter gehen entweder wir kriegen hier
die kurve und zwar sehr entschlossen und
sehr bald oder wir werden da alle
parteien keine sehr naher zukunft ganz
ganz schwere see geraten und
gegebenenfalls scheitern das will ich
partout vermeiden vermeiden
ein scheitern auf das unsere gegner
sehnlichst warten und dass wir ihnen
eben nicht durch eigene
unzulänglichkeiten auch noch frei haus
liefern dürfen liebe freunde
machen mehr
machen wir uns das doch bewusst alle
bewusst es kommt auch auf uns an
seht doch her die merkel & co und unser
land in richtung abgrund zur abgrund
treiben und immer weiter kaputt machen
die werden bald mit den grünen regieren
wenn ich alles täuscht mit den grünen
sie machen neuerdings einen lauf
bürgerlich auf innere sicherheit und
terrorismusbekämpfung punkt sicher
anders er habe da verzapft
das ist völlig gaga die freunde restlos
offener grenzen und unbegrenzte
migration aus aller herren länder
gerieren sich nun ernsthaft als
vermeintlich harte bekämpfung von
kriminalität und islamistische terror in
europa mehr bock zum gärtner machen geht
doch gar nicht liebe freunde
wohin wohin wenn unser land mit diesen
leuten 1 ab herbst 21 treiben wenn die
hier regieren meine sorge um meine
heimat deutschland jedoch wohl auch
unsere gemeinsame sorge sie könnte
größer kaum sein
und wir stehen hier in der unbedingten
verantwortung dieser an haupt und
gliedern falschen politik einen
vernünftigen einen bürgerlichen ein
konservativ freiheitlich geprägten
alternativen politik entgegen zu setzen
wer denn wenn nicht wir wir sind die
einzigen die das in diesem land machen
und machen müssen und währenddessen und
das ist das weswegen ich deswegen nicht
diese worte werden verhalten sich bei
uns einige wenige ich betone wenige
unreife und dieser verantwortung
offenkundig nicht gewachsen mitglieder
bis hin zu mandats und amtsträgern die
trotzige pubertierende mit lust und
billiger zuweilen regelhaft regelrecht
pflege haffter provokation in der sie
sicher noch geradezu selbst verliebt
gefallen
ich war vor einiger zeit einen unserer
bayerischen mdbs in tv bildern auf einer
demo bei der ist geradezu gezielt man
konnte das sehen darauf anlegte in eine
rempelei mit der polizei zu beraten was
sie mir auch gelangen und ihn dann zu
einer gespielten theatralischen
entrüstung veranlasste in der sich als
opfer zu inszenieren offenkundig gefiel
und da sage ich so etwas liebe freunde
ist kindergarten das ist unwürdig das
schadet uns und mir meinen das muss
unterbleiben das geht nicht
solche aktionen solche aktionen und das
macht mich eben zornig und ich glaube
erfahren sie hier heraus solche aktionen
reifen ganz entspannt mit dem
allerwertesten wieder ein wofür tausende
andere parteimitglieder sich tag für tag
in akribischer und aufopferungsvolle
arbeit für die partei und ihre ziele
einsetzen
das können wir uns nicht leisten und
dass wir da unsere aufgabe für das
vaterland nicht gerecht unser land
braucht eine seriöse politische
alternative und die können nach lage der
dinge nur wer sein wissen sie wir haben
so viele so gute leute in unseren reihen
die harte und fachlich exzellente arbeit
leisten in den kommunalparlamenten in
den landtagen im bundestag
in dem im eu-parlament auch in den
vielen fachausschüssen
das dürfen wir uns nicht unter keinen
umständen von denen kaputt machen lassen
die er vom systemwechsel und
außerparlamentarische opposition
schwärmen das ist nicht afd
das sind nicht wir die davon schwärmen
was wir brauchen
als partei unbedingt brauchen und ganz
schnell lernen müssen ist deswegen
disziplin
ich habe auf dem bundesparteitag in
braunschweig vor genau einiger
eingefordert dass wir unsere
professionalisierung entschlossen
vorantreiben müssen und ohne disziplin
geht das nicht und ich sage es klar wir
haben keine zeit mehr
die zeit drängt wer also gerne weiter
revolution oder politik kav rolle
spielen will kann kann und sollte das
dann woanders tun aber bitte nicht in
der ard
denn nur mit eiserner disziplin mit
sachlicher vernunft mit harter und
seriöse und deshalb bessere arbeit als
jene der anderen parteien können wir
unsere aufgabe als konservative
rechtsstaatspartei wird nicht gerecht
werden nur so können wir den dienst an
unserem vaterland erbringen der uns doch
die motivation für die tägliche
politische arbeit ist und uns überhaupt
erst hierher gebracht hat liebe freunde
darum machen wir das doch alles neben
die ganzen mühen auf und lassen uns ohne
jede inhaltliche rechtfertigung als was
nicht alles beschimpfen und verleumden
west ihren unsere häuser für uns und
unsere autos abgefackelt zu bekommen
sterben unsere kleinen und auch größeren
sozialen tode als verfemter afd schlagen
und zwei wochen tage und abende und
ungezählte komplette wochenenden um die
ohren die man stattdessen noch gemütlich
mit der familie verbringen könnte die
kernfrage meine damen und herren ist in
dieser phase die oder jeder möge die
sich sehr ernsthaft stellen und
beantworten was wollen wir kapitulieren
mir vor dem oft übermächtig erscheinende
links rot-grünen sozialistischen
zeitgeist oder halt mir wirklich
entschlossen dagegen und wenn wir
entschlossen dagegen halten und das ist
aus meiner sicht unsere verdammte
pflicht da geht das eben nicht mit einem
zirkus kunterbunt in dem jeder seine
eigene vorstellung und inszenierung nach
die eigenem gusto abhält sondern geht
das nur mit einer disziplinierten denn
sauber organisierten und klar
strukturierten alternative für
deutschland
ich habe meine antwort ich habe für mich
meine antworten liebe freunde und ich
glaube ihr wisst ich will ein
deutschland mit vollen bürgerlichen
freiheiten und pflichten nach einer gibt
es nicht ohne das andere
ich will einen deutschland mit
fortbestehen der nationaler souveränität
statt ihre aufgabe für ein kunstgebilde
namens vereinigte staaten von europa
ich will einen deutschland mit einer
schlechten note äußerst restriktiven
begrenzung jeder zuwanderung in einer
konsequenten ab und ausweisung aller
nicht bleibe berechtigten ich will einen
deutschland mit florierender wirtschaft
unter einem fairen und freiheitlichen
ordnungsrahmen in deutschland mit einer
bezahlbaren ökologisch sinnvollen das
heißt von nuklearer hochtechnologie
stadt ineffizient und landschaft
zerstören den windrädern gespeisten
energieversorgung
ich will in deutschland mit dem auch in
vielen in dem auch in vielen jahren noch
autos mit hoch effizienten
verbrennungsmotoren hergestellt und
gefahren werden und in deutschland in
deutschland ohne verschandelung unserer
kultur sprache durch binnen stern finde
stotter und sonstiges gender gap
kurzum ich will ein land in dem nicht
nur wir sondern vor allem auch unsere
kinder und enkel tatsächlich und nicht
billiger und abgedroschener werbeslogan
einer ausgemergelten union noch gut und
gerne und unbedrängt und frei werden
leben können und das gibt es nicht
geschenkt und diejenigen die sich
anschicken uns in unseren nachfahren all
das zu nehmen
die sind in ihrem ansinnen schon
verdammt weit fortgeschritten
das zu verhindern und den hebel doch
noch umzulegen auf vernunft dafür treten
wir an ich glaube nicht dass ich mit
dieser antwort jedem saal allein bin
nicht im saal nicht in der partei nicht
im volk wenn wir dieses gemeinsame wenn
wir diese einheit der partei so angehen
mit vernunft mit maß und mitte und
zugleich mit trotziger entschlossenheit
im wort wie im auftritt dann ist das die
einheit die ich von ganzem herzen will
und für die ich gerne mit euch gemeinsam
weiter kämpfe so lange meine kräfte mich
tragen für mein land
für mein land für eine stolze
kulturnation die weit mehr ist als eine
provinz brüssel
für menschen wie hier in freiheit leben
sollen heute und in aller zukunft für
deutschland vielen dank
[Applaus]